hey youtubers it's Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Doctor Who QA again it's
just part one of the finale part two
next week hopefully we'll get all of our
questions answered in case some of you
haven't seen the episode yet just
blanket spoiler warning for missy's true
identity I know there were some
questions about whether or not she might
be lying about who she is Moffat pretty
much answered that during the Doctor Who
extra episode what he said is is that he
just really likes Michelle Gomez's
version of the master and thinks that
she's going to be much scarier for
children I'm just taking that to be
confirmation that she is in fact the
master or the mistress however you want
to think about it and will continue to
be so indefinitely just a funny and
terrifying version to mary poppins that
can regenerate and for those asking
whether or not this is heralding a
future female doctor I don't think that
Moffat cast her as a test for a future
female doctor I think he just felt that
she was the perfect person for who he
wanted the master to be I don't think
there's any other secret agenda so let's
answer some questions question number
one geo X machinima asks what
regeneration do you think missy is in
depending on which regeneration you
think derek jacobi is i would say she's
got at least half of her regenerations
left probably more than that what we
don't know is is how many regenerations
john simm has burned since he got
trapped in the pocket universe with
Gallifrey technically at the end of time
that was the time-lock Gallifrey the
pocket universe didn't happen till after
the fiftieth there are so many questions
about what happened after the fiftieth
i'm hoping the second part of the finale
answers those they might bring up the
issue of Capaldi's remaining
regenerations personally i think he has
a whole new cycle I don't think that
Missy's gonna try and steal those were
generations I think she's got plenty I
think that trying to add that in would
already over complicate this invasion
plot but it is possible they could do
that question number two Hagar asks how
far back in time has Missy been stealing
dead people since she's so preoccupied
with Clara I would say that she has all
of the Clara's all the way back to
Victorian Clara using that as a
benchmark just say everyone since
Victorian times again also raises a
whole lot of questions about how the
master got there does he have a TARDIS
is that red phone booth his TARDIS or
her TARDIS just more things that the
finale has to explain if she has been
saving people
that would mean that she has the bodies
of all the previous doctor who
companions that's an interesting thought
so hopefully the finales going to follow
up on that question number three
Schroedinger the cat ass what was up
with Missy saying the one you abandoned
I think that's just a reference to the
end of time I think the master knew
about the doctor saving gal Frank and
felt like the doctor abandoned him
inside that pocket universe even though
the 50th changed the timeline a little
bit I think that all the time lords and
time ladies whoever's on Gallifrey has
knowledge of what happened and what
preceded it so they'll know about time
lock Gallifrey there's the issue of
rassilon what's going on with him
everyone that's left there I will say
I'll be a little bit upset if they don't
address what happened between end of
time and the fiftieth on Gallifrey
sometimes it can get a bit timey wimey
with exposition pushing number for
shadow ask couldn't the doctor just snap
his fingers and open the TARDIS yes
there are actually a couple people that
can do that like you said though he was
just testing to see how far Clara would
go I think the explanation is that car
doesn't know other people can snap their
fingers to open the TARDIS she doesn't
know it's a really easy thing the other
way to explain it is that the keys are
something like siege mode and they lock
the TARDIS down in a way that finger
snapping can't fix best guess though is
that Clara was just off her rocker and
wasn't thinking about the finger
snapping question number 5 adrian s if
missy was able to get out of the pocket
universe where Gallifrey is do you think
the doctor will ask her about it and how
to find it definitely I think they'll
absolutely talk about Gallifrey we've
spent all of series 8 not talking about
Gallifrey what happened in the 50th was
just too big to completely ignore for an
entire season so at some point the
master will have to explain how he
escaped presumably using Time Lord
technology the big question there is if
the master could escape how come all the
other Time Lords didn't escape to even
though all the time lords and time
ladies are special the doctor and the
master our extra special so you could
just look at them as being a little more
clever presumably the master figured
something out that the other time lords
and time ladies could not figure out
question number 6 junior creeper asks do
you think that Missy will be a recurring
villain like the classic versions of the
master and do you think the Cybermen
need a break again like the class except
to this episode so about missing yes I
think she will be recurring at least
until Michelle Gomez can't play the
character anymore
moffat feels like he has a new idea
that's better just in general I would
expect her to stick around as long as
Capaldi sticks around as for the
Cybermen I know you're talking about the
invasion like after that invasion
episode during the second doctors run
they didn't show up for something like
five years Moffat has used the Cybermen
quite a bit so I wouldn't mind if he
retired them for a little while he did
come up with the silence so I'm looking
forward to them creating some new
monsters for series 9 question number 7
Tammy asks if the master could
regenerate into a woman does that mean
the doctor could as well yes he totally
can they could basically look like
whatever they want to look like
sometimes it requires more effort
classic who explained the mechanics of
regeneration just a little bit better
for all intents and purposes though the
doctor can look like whatever he wants
to look like or he can make it a random
thing question number eight Joe asked do
you think we'll see a regeneration from
symptom Missy and if not do you think
that Moffat would use it to do another
revision like he did with the war doctor
oh you mean like inserting someone into
their timeline yes I do think that it's
possible we'll see a regeneration from
symptom Missy even though Johnson does
have another show on BBC america it's
totally possible that he came in for a
one-off scene I think they'll at least
explained the regeneration even if they
don't show it I'm not expecting Moffat
to do a war doctor thing though that was
just something to explain the break in
Doctor Who after the Doctor Who movie
and before the 2005 series started so I
don't think they'll be an equivalent
Warmaster it'll be sim to missy and
that's it question number 9 Tom asks if
missy is collecting skeletons how many
do you think she has well she said the
dead outnumber the living so it would
have to be more than like six or seven
billion however many people are alive
today it would be more than that I don't
know how they'll show that on screen
because that is a hell a lot of Cybermen
they have had some pretty good special
effects during series 8 but I think
mostly we'll see stuff happening in
London right around st. Paul's Cathedral
that's just where they were filming most
of the outdoor scenes question number 10
knickknacks as if Clara leaves do you
think that Missy would travel with the
doctor next no I actually think that we
would meet the next companion during the
Christmas special just like we did when
we met car for the first time even
though Clara became the first companion
and then died in that same episode that
was a bit of a bummer hopefully they'll
explain why the master or the mistress
chose Clara and how that ties into
Victorian Clara
thank you so much everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do again so many questions left that
the finale has to answer hopefully
they'll wrap all those things up
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner temporal Thane you win an amazon
gift card be sure to message me on my
channel or somewhere on social like
twitter or facebook for details so one
more episode to go and then we have
about two solid months of no Doctor Who
then Christmas special and then we can
talk about Sherlock lots of Sherlock
coming so right now click here for my
episode 11 video and click here for my
episode 10 video thank you so much for
watching so let's all high five and I'll
see you guys tonight
you